Joining me today is the original king of
interviewing,
a friend,
a mentor,
a living legend,
and a man who loves a good Brooklyn
Water Bagel.
Larry King,
welcome to the Rubin report.
No one ever I hear legend.
I think one thing old.
Well,
and every time we've sat down,
I always,
I,
I feel that I have to say living legend
at the beginning because you are.
Tell us.
One of the best compliments I ever got
was Derek jeter.
Great Yankee.
Now on over the Marlin's came over to me
at the All star game some years ago and
said,
you.
He said there were a lot of phony
legends.
You're a true lunch.
Wow,
that's pretty good.
Yeah.
That warm my heart and that's coming
from a legend because that kind of guys
the true baseball fee too.
Did you ever think that after all your
years in radio and cable news now doing
the digital thing,
that you'd be sitting in a garage being
interviewed like this,
going out to hundreds of thousands and
millions of people?
Well,
let me tell you the truth.
This is the pinnacle of my career.
If you'd have told me 61 years ago when
I started 61 years from today,
you will be known around the world.
You'll be called an icon,
a living legend,
and at the height of your career you'll
be in a garage with David Ruben.
It's come full circle.
It's killing me,
Larry David.
But what does that,
what does that say about just how
everything has changed?
I mean,
the only thing sures change,
the only thing constant is change.
When I started in radio,
we had landlines,
a webpro phone line.
I did starting regular,
did local television one year after I
started audio.
Always did both.
Always regarded both equally.
Uh,
I always thought of television is radio
with pictures.
We can be on a radio now.
Yeah.
Well we released this as an audio file.
I know,
but they don't have to see it.
Yeah,
we could imagine.
And he's radio is theater of the mind,
but I always took it as just
communicating.
So I started in radio them,
did local television,
then did national radio and satellites.
I was there when satellites were
introduced.
I never forgot it.
I'm in Washington,
the guest is in La and it feels like
he's right there.
Yeah,
right there.
It was amazing saddle.
I said satellites.
That's the end that completes it.
Then Ted Turner hired me through CNN and
I'm seeing around the world.
We go up 23,000
miles to go next door and to Moscow.
Try to explain that to Jefferson doing
hot and now after 20 years,
almost 26 years at CNN,
61 years in the business I thought I
could retire.
Follow slim came along so we go do
something.
So the internet or a TV or Hulu.
Who knew from this and when you tell me
about the Internet,
what bugs me is when a hill is it?
Where is the Internet and people talk
about the Internet and I even though I
just have to accept it,
correct.
I'm a product of all these things,
but basically David,
I am doing exactly what I did 61 years
ago.
What we're doing right now is no
different.
Yeah,
we're being delivered differently,
but what we're doing and what does that
say about this?
The ability to sit across from somebody,
look them in the eye and actually try to
understand the human experience because
I was saying to you in the green room
right before there is a massive
renaissance right now because of
podcasts,
about long form conversation,
the thing that you've been doing for 60,
some ideas,
that's where it's happening and
podcasts.
It's not happening on television.
Not even on cable toe.
They used to call,
you know MSNBC,
CNN and Fox news channels.
They're not new shells.
They have prompt channels.
Is pro trump.
Anti trump won sometimes hate trump and
there's pundits.
Yeah,
it's 24 hours a day of punditry.
They do not cover the news.
When the hurricane was hitting Carolina,
it was in a box on the corner of the
screen.
While we're talking about trump.
You saw where the hurricane was.
That's not news.
Do you remember seeing a change on that
because you were at CNN,
you remember what year you started at
the end?
I started in 1985 and left in 2010.
Yeah.
Do you remember seeing something
changing in the way the news reported
and the sword?
When the other side started?
You know,
we owned it for a while,
CNN,
and then it was MSNBC,
Fox,
and we thought they were little
invaders.
Ted Turner was a genius.
Yeah,
an office pants genius of the seat of
the pants.
He was driving in a car one day and the
guy said,
all news all the time.
He said,
why could not work on television?
Then he puts it up on the big bird.
Look what He.
He is the revolutionary leader of the
second half of the 20th century.
Changes the world and look where it's
come to now,
the Internet.
Now you're everywhere.
You know the different side.
There's good and bad to it.
If something happened in the world right
now,
David,
everyone knows that in a minute.
In a minute,
the world knows it.
Wow.
Yeah.
What do we do with this?
Technology is always ahead of the human
advance,
so when technology's ahead,
it's how do we grasp using this?
It's a great pie interview with Steve
Jobs when he started apple and I'm
wondering if he were here today,
if he would know what an impact that's
had in the world because I've had
experts told me that your iphone will
control your life.
Basically.
It's controlling our lives right now.
This is a perfect segway,
my friend.
Can you bust out your phone?
I do not have an iphone because I don't
want to be.
I was addicted to tobacco from age 17 to
age 53 when I had a heart attack.
I know what addiction is.
I would wake up in the morning and
grabbed the cigarette before I put my
glasses on.
Anything.
I see people,
my wife friends with their cell phones.
I have been with a friend.
I'd never talked to him.
We sit at dinner and I mean and he's A.
I think they get from cancer,
so I have old school.
A flip phone.
See his phone?
Yeah.
It's a phone.
Put it to your ear.
You hear the other side?
I don't text.
I hit people.
They call me.
I called them normal.
You're the only person that I actually
call.
You do realize that I don't call
anybody.
I just take.
Why don't you.
Why use this hurts me.
You as a broadcaster.
As a communicator?
Yeah.
Why do you text?
All right.
I could see an emergency.
I'm stuck.
I'll be late.
Yeah,
but come on sometimes people will look,
you know,
this is what I love to do,
but sometimes just for the sake of ease
of just I'm going to be here then or
I'll see you there.
You know,
a lot of that.
I try not to have long form discussions
about political will lose or.
But yeah,
people are fighting over personal things
on there and all of that.
But wait,
I want,
I want it back into the thing he said
before because.
So when the satellite started and then
you suddenly we're doing interviews with
people where you weren't in the same
room.
Do you remember that affecting the
interview in La?
Because I always liked this.
I don't want nothing like that.
Nothing beats this.
Nothing.
However.
I always try to treat it as this.
They just weren't there,
so I try to make eye contact via the
satellite.
I try to treat it as if they were there
and what I got used to handling well and
enjoyed was when I've had five different
guests in five different places and
controlling that.
Yeah,
and then I did diplomacy.
I had a night where we had a Arafat
route being and the king,
the King of Jordan,
King Abdullah,
not Avila,
his father.
Okay.
All three.
Kissinger told me you were doing
diplomacy.
I had our fat king of Jordan and the
prime minister of Israel together.
Me a little Jewish kid from Brooklyn
sitting there by satellite,
but I felt I was with them.
I didn't treat it as them being there.
I treated as like this.
Yeah.
Did you in,
in some of the bigger interviews that
you did over the years,
I mean,
you've interviewed,
you've truly interviewed everybody.
Is there anyone that you felt like you
didn't,
you didn't get
Castro?
I went down to Cuba in 19,
in 20.
Oh,
nine slash two old nun.
I was treated legally.
They all wonderful to me,
but I couldn't nail it.
Couldn't get them to do.
I was fascinated by him because he led
his country longer than any leader in
memory.
Somebody had a like them.
Even if it was only one person,
and then when I went to Havana,
I never saw a happier country.
I was amazed the people smiling,
musical hotels,
mobbed,
you know,
Canadians,
Germans and beautiful weather,
Beautiful City Water Havana,
or to be open to everybody.
It's beautiful.
The water's up or just.
It's a great city.
How aware were you when you're
interviewing big timers,
the real movers and shakers that the
ravines and Arafat's that you mentioned,
that something that you ask them could
actually turn the course of history?
No,
I'm not aware of.
I know a lot of it did.
I know the parole board debate changed
Nafta.
We Clinton called me up the next day and
said,
you pass enough to.
That was way behind until the go pro or
pro debate.
You try not to read,
but once once the light goes on.
That's just a moment.
I'm in Illinois.
I if I'm sitting with Jimmy Carter or a
ballet dancer,
once the light goes on,
I'm in that moment.
I don't think about yesterday.
Can't do anything about it.
Don't think about tomorrow.
That's tomorrow.
So I'm in the now so I'm right in this
now.
You should be in this now.
So if you've got trump coming tomorrow
and you're thinking about that,
then you're losing this moment.
I'm here.
I always treat.
I,
oh,
I focused.
Do you.
I think that that your curiosity,
do you think you sort of made that for
yourself or was it built into you?
Because I've been out with you to lunch
or to dinner,
breakfast,
whatever it is,
and I can see you're as curious about
the waiter.
Every busboy or sometime when we were at
ora together and you'd be chatting with
the guy doing the lights or whatever,
that you were actually as interested in
them as if
David.
I remember as a kid getting on a bus,
kip and asking the bus driver,
why do you want to drive a bus?
I remember we'd go to ball games,
kid in Brooklyn,
go to dodger games,
go with my friends.
We'd wait outside for the players.
They wanted autographs.
I never want them in order to grow.
I wanted to ask questions.
I would run along with a player going to
his car.
Why did.
Why did you bunt?
Why'd you do that?
I was always a white person.
I'm the kind of person you don't want to
sit next to on an airplane.
I.
I'm in sand.
I don't know where that came from,
but it's the best gift I got was
curious.
The gift of curiosity.
Anthony Quinn told me that you have the
greatest gift ever.
Curiosity,
my friend Herby Cohen.
You can negotiate anything says to me.
The secret of my success is being
stupid.
It doesn't mean that demeaning.
Basically what you're doing is saying,
help me.
Help me with this.
Why'd you do that?
Someone asked me a few it interviewed or
some have been loud with your first
question a bit while it would not have
been,
why did you bomb the World Trade Center?
It would have been you grew up in one of
the richest families in Saudi Arabia.
Why don't you leave now?
He probably hadn't bought a lot since he
left,
but it forces you to think and then I'm
going to learn more about him before I
learned about the bombing and also you
have to understand that nobody,
nobody thinks they're evil.
Hitler did not comb his hair in the
morning and say,
I am a bad person.
They may be crazy,
but they believe nobody thinks for
really terrible and everyone has an
excuse for what they do.
The bankruptcy,
the bank,
but my father,
they charged his checking account that
screwed up and the public funding enough
admires the renegade.
Dylan.
Joe was very popular in America.
Very popular.
He robbed from banks who likes banks.
Right?
So how do you then interview a bad dude?
Someone that's got your curious.
You're curious about a bad dude.
I.
I try not to.
It's hard sometimes racists especially.
Yeah,
I had a tough time doing the early
George Wallace.
The later George Wallace was terrific.
The early George was a tough time
because I don't understand racism.
I've never understood it,
I don't have no understanding of why
someone would a different pigment.
That's all it is.
Should be treated differently.
You think that comes from just growing
up in Brooklyn and it is what?
It was such a medicaid.
Can you just talk about that a little
bit?
Like what that was like growing up.
Oh,
I grew up in a neighborhood of making,
you know,
Jews,
Protestants,
Catholics,
some,
not a lot,
but blacks went to school at us.
When I went down to Miami to break into
radio,
I was 23 and I got off the train and the
first thing I saw were two water
fountains,
colored white.
I drank out of it.
Yeah.
I'd never seen anything like that.
You grew up in Brooklyn.
That was beyond me.
Then I got on a bus to go over to Miami
beach to stay with my uncle and the bus
drivers stuffs the bus and asked me to
move forward because the back is for
blacks and I said to him,
my father's black,
I'll stay in the back.
So I never.
I never understood it and I've asked
this a racist.
I have never understood why a wife feels
superior to a black.
Lenny Bruce,
who was a great friend of mine,
used to tell me that the human being has
to have something they hate that drives
them because they have an inferiority
complex so they have to feel superior or
something,
and he told me 40 years ago,
Sunday blacks will get equal rights and
we'll have to hate something.
I'll tell you what,
we'll hate eskimos.
There's always another right.
In other words,
you know,
used to check into a hotel and
underneath the chair would be assigned,
remove under penalty of law.
You know,
who removes him Eskimos,
you know,
and he asked for a war.
Heroes.
Yeah.
You don't know name one.
I can't.
I'm going to google that.
I've got an Eskimo doctor.
They would look for.
They were just trying to find some and
racism.
Always be photo.
I interviewed Dean Rusk,
secretary of State Kennedy years,
and he was a very progressive southerner
from Georgia.
His daughter married a black man.
He has.
He said,
I have no prejudice.
Seamless.
They taught me a little about prejudice
of mouth.
The next Dean Rusk said to me,
my daughter married a black man.
I had black grandchild.
I have no prejudice.
I got on a commercial plane.
The pilot was black and for a minute I
was nervous that Sergio how inbred or
can be can he fly the plane,
but I've never boggles me.
When you win over the years when you've
talked to some of these people,
you know,
white supremacists or just some of these
people that come from that truly racist
place,
did you ever hear them say anything?
Was it almost like therapy in a way that
you felt if you talk to them long
enough,
maybe they could get out of it?
Did you ever.
Since
you try,
you try the best you can now as some
books out by former white supremacists
who come full circle.
If,
of course they raised a lot to do with
raising as the major inferiority.
You got to deal with that.
Although someone said it's not a complex
tear inferior.
Who were some of the people that you
interviewed that,
uh,
that you think either it went the wrong
way or any regrets and never sitting
down with somebody to go,
Oh man,
I missed that mall.
I could tell you.
One is the one trying to remember his
name now.
The guy who succeeded Steve Jobs,
they want immediate while Tim Cook now,
but it's not essential.
Yeah.
Steve jobs hired him.
Oh,
what was his name?
Bright Guy came from Pepsi Cola.
I think I'll have my guys google it.
Well,
and he ran,
he ran and I had them on for two hours.
Yeah.
Great guest in our fresh.
Why was it?
Why was it was his partner.
Okay.
Oh,
this guy,
we're play joined the cooperation.
Steve left out.
Then came back later.
Okay,
well we'll grab it.
So I spent two hours interviewing this
guy.
He was great.
All about previous jobs and,
and then I finished and now I go to
calls.
I used to do this on my own radio show
to our interview and our calls in an
open phone America.
I go to close the first call,
Larry.
Steve jobs fired him.
He replaced Steve Jobs and steve jobs
fired him.
They didn't even ask about that shit or
no.
Yeah,
it's tough when one gets by it.
Right,
and it haunts you.
Look at it is years ago is still
haunting.
You try to know everything.
You can't.
There's no perfectly interview.
You can't know everything.
You do the best shit can.
I had a tough time with child other ran
because he would remember.
He was talking to me on scully,
I think is the guy.
Does it?
John Sculley?
See we've got a crack team.
Okay,
there you go.
He's still around.
By the way.
When I interviewed Alma dinner,
John and we're talking about various
things and we're talking about the
Holocaust and he says to me as well,
I always have to listen when you do an
interview.
He said,
if there was a holocaust,
why isn't Israel in Poland?
That's where the crime occurred.
Why is the state of Israel 2000 miles
away?
There was no crime in Palestine.
The crime was in Poland to Germany.
Why didn't they take that area and give
it to Israel?
Right.
It made some sense.
You could argue with logically.
Yeah.
I said to him,
did you say if there was a whole
and we went into just right there.
Are you saying if I,
you know,
when we got contentious,
you deny was.
Those are interesting,
but look,
I've had so many years doing this,
Dave and I can't explain how I still
love it.
I love the interplay.
You should love what you do not know why
you're learning something every day,
every day.
So I can't be closed minded like I'm a
liberal politically,
certainly in social issues,
but I'm not closed minded enough to
think that you can have an opposing
view.
I liked the argument,
I liked the discussion,
but in interviewing,
I never leave my ego at the door.
I try not to use the word I to relevant
and I tried to get into walk in another.
You know Edward Bennett Williams is a
great lawyer.
Told me once,
I said,
what is the role of the criminal defense
lawyer?
He said to get one person on the jury to
walk in your client's shoes,
if you can get one person to walk in
your client's shoes,
got a hung jury.
All he has to do is say,
I would have done that.
Yeah.
When you were doing five nights a week
and on any good.
I use this example a lot because people
will say,
oh Dave,
you had this,
you know,
this bad person on or this,
that.
The other thing I'll say,
you know,
in,
in Larry King's Hay day,
let's go 1992 CNN.
You'd have the cast of friends on
Monday,
you'd have an Oj Simpson lawyer.
On Tuesday you'd have,
you know,
an animal guy on Wednesday you'd have,
a doctor on,
on Thursday and then you know,
former secretary of state on Friday.
Was that crazy for you?
You just love the bounce part of my
curiosity.
Yeah,
most of the Times,
most of the times driving in,
I didn't know I had on that night.
Really?
I still don't know Laura.
I drive in.
I don't know who's on.
Unless it was really someone famous,
like we might have the animal guy I
didn't know until I walk in and see all
the animals and because my curiosity
comes from pure curiosity.
So were your guys hand and you know.
No,
no.
I get a blue card.
Like I had a blue card with fax.
Yeah.
He was secretary of state from year.
She ended that year.
He was responsible for the Marshall
Plan.
Right.
That's all.
And then I would do the things that are
the Marshall Plan came about?
Yeah.
How we're part of it.
Did you play with George Marshall?
Was his plan?
Were you in on the thinking?
You know,
it's all when when we have the Gulf War,
I would see other shows in which the
guests would come on and be general or
something and the host would say today
and the Gulf War,
1000 people were killed and the thing
and now terrain is here and all I would
say is what happened?
What happened today?
Because he has the perspective.
If you have an interview where you turn
the TV on and the host is on more than a
guest,
something's wrong.
If you.
If it takes you three sentences to ask a
question,
something's wrong,
because a lot of them are show offs.
I'll give you the show off interviewer,
right?
Yeah.
I guess today is Dave Rubin.
He's written a new book called Chicago.
My hometown.
Been great to have you here.
Dave.
You know I visited Chicago many times.
Always loved going there.
Did you,
do you.
Do you write about the stock yard,
you know,
or stuck study as a fascinating.
Do you ever go to that folks in other.
Otherwise you are a prop for me and
that's gone now though.
There aren't even low shows anymore.
Yeah.
What do you make of.
So when you left at the end,
and I've said this to you before you
left in 2010,
it seems to me you can do a pretty clean
line between you leaving Sienna and
obviously the piers Morgan thing didn't
work out.
If you want to comment on how you can,
but that you were one of the people that
people trusted that there's almost no
one in news or on television anymore,
that people go,
oh,
like no one was walking around.
Even the people that maybe didn't like
it that much,
they were going to Larry King's a bad
dude.
Larry King's a liar.
You know what I mean?
Nobody was doing that by having one of
the main faces who had been there for so
long.
I really think it broke something in the
continuity of CNN that kind of led us to
where we are now related to all of
cable.
Maybe.
Maybe it did.
There were signs,
you know,
Fox News was beating us.
We had one at all those years and Fox
News was beating and beating cnn the
day,
beating us at night.
That was a sign.
This was a network.
Does Not News,
but am I making this up?
When you left CNN,
you still at the highest rated show
on the second highest week.
We started,
uh,
fall.
Not precipitously,
but we started a fall.
We sort,
we can sort of infancy Saudian was CNN
always made a ton of money for.
They would have first and everybody in
America had CNN paid fifty cents a
month.
So Ted Turner that in on a genius
thinking this right now,
you and I are paying for CNN.
We're not watching it.
You don't pay for cvs,
you pay him for it.
He knew it.
So cnn made money.
If they had no commercials,
didn't do anything.
Just beyond public tune in.
It's a different world now.
I can't,
I don't know,
maybe it was the cleavage,
you know,
Jerry Seinfeld said,
my old column I used to do in usa today
when I did.
It's my two cents.
That was the beginning of twitter.
Yeah.
Really quick comments.
Uh,
but I,
I,
you know,
people call me a pioneer,
so I,
I,
all I see myself is,
I'm a lucky Jewish kid from Brooklyn who
was curious and that curiosity into a
career as I was able to take the natural
curiosity and make a career of it.
You think we're maybe running out of
that when you,
when you talk to younger than you have
to be very young sons.
When you talk to young people,
watch how they get the news.
You were telling me about kids with the
phones and everything and you've.
You love the newspaper,
right?
You are mine.
New York Times,
like I got an iphone.
They gave me an iphone,
so I use it to get baseball scores.
Yeah,
that's all.
I don't have it with me.
I don't know if the game is tonight.
You Go,
right?
You're.
I mean,
you're a major.
Still a dodger fan.
I love the game.
I go to basketball.
I love competition.
Your gradient at dodger stadium,
right?
Yeah.
I tell you why I love sports.
Sports is the one if you're not a sports
fan.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
The best thing about being a sports fan,
it's.
It's the one thing in your life when you
get up in the morning,
you don't know who's going to win,
so you have something to look forward
to.
Good or bad.
You don't know who's going to win.
Nobody wakes up with that.
Sports fans.
Another thing,
what I love about athletes,
maybe more than any professional,
their career is over when other careers,
the beginning they have that day when
the cheering stops,
you want that slide.
You build yourself up and you're 37
years old.
They paid you all this money for doing
what you did as a kid and another thing
the athlete has that we don't have final
score can argue that's it.
Eight to seven.
You lost,
you got seven,
they got eight.
You can say,
yeah,
but they should stop.
You got seven Bay guy.
Now if you got eight,
get the applause.
Get the down.
You get that every day.
Recognition.
Nonrecognition.
Walk down the street athletes,
so I love it,
so I love all it brings all my curiosity
sports.
Bring into a head because I'm always
interested in.
Last night the dodgers lost.
He left a lefthander into picks it.
His right hand buddies got all those
pitches in the dugout.
Why did they men?
Why did they leave him in?
Did you find there was something unique
about the top of the line athletes that
you would talk to that they,
that they genuinely had something
different or they had a guy,
the guys getting at
confidence?
Yeah,
that's it.
Stan musial the grape cardinal outfield
while he westlake was a teammate of his
and he,
while he told me this story,
it's the sitting in a dug up before a
game and Westlake those over to New
Zealand said,
Stan,
I got up this morning.
Breakfast was great.
The showers great to drive in was great,
and in batting practice I've had five
whole months.
I feel great.
You haven't had that kind of day,
Stan,
and he said every bit as good as get the
quarterback who throws 10 incomplete
passes,
never thinks about the 11 to have the
tenant complete effective confidence.
They have that ability.
You take wide receivers in football,
they're all fast.
They all have good hands.
The great one,
the great ones,
they bought me.
It's coming Gretzky.
He told me he saw the puck who into the
goal before it went into the corner and
so,
so I have great appreciation.
I also have appreciation for
politicians.
They do something we don't do.
They have a first Tuesday in November.
You know how that day,
they didn't have a first Tuesday in
November.
They went in lose.
They stand up before the public and they
win or lose.
They get rejected.
She kept telling me to satisfy day of
his life was flying home from his last
appearance when his advisors told them,
you know,
they know in the afternoon,
yeah,
you're going to lose.
The great story of Barbara Bush told me
when George Bush loss to Bill Clinton at
3:00
in the afternoon and they knew he was
going to lose and they're all sitting
around summer.
Barbara Bush came in and said,
where do we get a driver's license?
All right.
First off,
king,
we just did something that we've never
done on this.
We stopped for a moment so that Alexis
could bring you a chocolate shake in the
middle of the show.
Normally someone with diabetes heart
finish and not have a chocolate Mocha.
However,
I've lost weight and I don't know why
they say it comes with aging.
I have tried to have a daily milkshake
to not lose anymore.
That's a call back to Brooklyn,
right?
Oh yeah.
We had malteds to where they put Malt in
the candy store.
There's no candy stores anymore.
There's no camp.
Well now they've got like,
you know Beverly Hills Super Deluxe
about a candidate and a jukebox and you
sit in your Greens.
Yeah.
Well,
let's talk a little bit about age.
I guess it's a little weird to talk
about at some level.
You are 80?
I'll be 85 and November.
Okay.
So can't believe it.
My father died at 46.
I've had every known disease.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I'm this age.
What is it?
What does it feel like?
I mean,
you've,
you've had a heart attack,
diabetes,
a couple of things and you're still
here.
You're doing your thing.
You're out and about every morning I
bump into you.
Half the time
that,
uh,
is the reason I'm around is that I have
a purpose.
I am amazed that people who retire as
Milton Berle told me once when I asked
him,
are you going to retire?
And he said to what?
What would I do if I get up in the
morning?
I had nothing to do.
That's terrible.
So I have a place to go to follow my
profession.
That's wonderful.
If you can keep that going,
I'll probably die on the air.
I'll someone asked,
what would you like?
You really want to increase?
My Youtube view is right now.
Came from,
what would you like your obituary to
read?
And I said the oldest man who ever lived
passed away today and his sleep with a
smile on his face,
but you still get a kick out of
everything.
I know it so well.
Just real quick to tell everybody a
little bit about.
You have these breakfasts with your.
Yeah,
well some of them have passed away.
Gosh,
I grew up with in Brooklyn,
but we have a crew of about five or six
we made every day at different places
and we attained a to David.
We solve the problems of the world
today.
We solved the wrap.
Yeah.
Audience.
No worries about Iraq.
The table solved mostly through jokes.
The jokes that we talked about,
people getting in arguments,
we talk about Israel,
we talk about hearings,
who's this,
what's this senator doing,
what's he doing?
And then we also discuss Sinatra and old
time musicians and who's doing what and
what and Barbara streisand make on our
last tour and so we never know where the
discussion is going and that's the
wonderful.
And when you going to have friends from
childhood.
Two of mine have passed away,
but I still have to others.
The best thing about it is
I'm not Larry King and Larry Soccer,
that was my first name and they're very
happy for me,
but I'm still a button.
Your buttons on your shirt,
you know what I mean?
They,
they don't treat you like anything
different.
What's it like as somebody of a certain
age now where you know,
you just mentioned you've lost some
childhood friends.
Your brother passed away just last year
or so months ago.
Yeah.
I'm just watching life turn in that way.
That's the sad.
As Sinatra told me once,
the saddest about aging is your friends
go before you.
I didn't want.
My brother had died before me know your
younger brother and he was 80.
He was 80.
He lost his hard.
It's because I don't believe in
afterlife.
I'm not religious.
I think this is a baby.
That's it.
I've never.
I've interviewed thousands of people.
People who said they've seen death and
all this.
I don't buy it.
Maybe a little.
I just.
It just makes no sense to me that
Lincoln is up there or that there's
someone up there looking down on me.
I went to my grandchildren's.
They're twins,
boy and a girl.
So they had a bot and a bar Mitzvah,
and for the first time in ages,
I read from the Old Testament that God,
he's the son of a bitch cheese.
Did he hate it?
A lot.
My Enemies.
Lou out the show me one good pen.
My God,
believe in me.
Above me.
He was vain.
Incredible.
He was a Donald Trump before there was a
Donald Trump believe in me.
Above all others.
I am the.
I can't believe so when I read that,
I couldn't believe so I can't buy it.
I've interviewed all the great religious
leaders except pope.
I've never been convinced.
So when you,
when you've sat down,
I sat down with everybody from the Dalai
Lama across the board with Bray Graham
was a friend.
Yeah.
So when you sat down with them,
even if you don't believe it,
did you feel that some of them were able
to get something out of belief?
I believe they believe.
Yeah.
Unless there was some nice,
you know,
send in $10 and I'll send you a little
cross gonna buy any of that.
Sat Down with some of those guys.
Do Jerry Falwell since,
as George Burns once said,
when he played God,
it's a great movie,
great movie,
Great.
And he got us all the religious leaders
and he calls into Jerry Falwell type and
fall type.
Go See.
Call me in.
First goes up to his room,
sits down and God says to him,
why don't you sold shoes?
So I never,
I never bought that part,
but I,
I liked billy Graham respected,
um,
billy grand,
thought I was very spiritual.
And do I believe billy is with Jesus
now?
No.
But bill,
he believed he believed he was going to
Jesus.
He had no fear.
Death had a fear of being in a plane
that's gone down to crash,
but he didn't fear death.
I feared I like Woody Allen.
I don't fear it.
I just don't want to be there.
I can't believe my wife believes.
I respect believers.
See,
when I approach an interview with Billy
Graham,
I respect him.
I asked him best questions I could ask
like,
why do you need to stay at the
Fontainebleau?
Or I've quoted Lenny.
Bruce Timm.
Any person who's got a calling from the
Lord to lead the flock who has more than
one suit while someone has no clothes,
is a cop out.
And Billy Graham said,
in today's world,
you have to have more than one suit.
You have to travel.
I asked him if Christ Jesus probably had
one pair of flip flops,
crease would Christ,
will he buy suits?
And he said yes.
And he would go on television.
That was a means of communication.
Yeah,
I mean that's their answer,
but he believed it.
I respected his belief,
but I'm not afraid to ask them any
question if when you die,
if you believe in Jesus Christ,
you will live forever.
What happens to the Jews?
And he said,
well,
I,
I don't go into them,
but maybe at the moment of their death
they accept Christ.
That's kind of a cop out.
There's always sort of another answer.
Did you ever talk to anybody,
either religious or otherwise,
that you felt had some sort of special
insight into some of the.
Does Dr Ron,
who was convinced that he had died,
visited what the world of afterlife was,
and then his life was saved.
He was recognized.
Dr You know what disease he had.
I threw it up to a vivid imagination and
ain't got a best selling book out of it.
People want to believe,
you know,
I wished that I had faith that I could
make.
It's called a leap.
Faith can't prove it,
so it's a leap of faith.
Now we have faith in a lot of things.
You get on an airplane,
you have the faith that that airplane
company hired a licensed pilot.
I punch you.
Have some core belief that you think if
you jump out of the 10th floor of a
building,
you're not going to make it so you don't
trump the people who have that faith who
go beyond.
I just think they've got a great crutch,
Greg Crutch to know you're going
somewhere.
Yeah.
But at the end,
do you think it matters if they,
if they live a good life and you live a
good life?
First of all,
I've never gotten to know.
Yeah.
If they go somewhere they were right.
If they don't,
they don't know because they did,
so they got a good deal going.
They really have a good deal.
I don't have an RBC.
If I've got an afterlife,
I'll be shocked.
But you'll be doing this.
Oh,
I was absolute.
Or maybe you'll be playing baseball up
there.
I'm not that good decade.
Um,
let's talk a little bit about politics.
You mentioned trump.
We did about 40 minutes.
His name didn't even come up once.
First Time in American conversation,
any
two people had a conversation for 40
minutes in the name trump that that's
one thing he's done.
I'll bet you everyone in America at one
time today said the name trump.
Everybody.
Is there anyone else that in the years
that you've been doing this that you
saw?
Just that effect?
He's the only president that I've known
for 40 years.
I met the other presidents some before
they became President Barack Obama,
George Bush,
Bill Clinton.
But they were in the political sphere,
but trump is the only one that was my
friend before trump and I went to the
superbowl together.
Can you talk about what I will fathers
of the year together?
Is that a 1995?
He had his kids and my kids as all of
his story.
We got trophies.
Um,
I went to see Marla maples in her
Broadway show.
I went with trump.
I stayed at hotels when I had some minor
surgery in New York.
He took my wife out to dinner the night
before.
He caught me at every hotel he owned,
put me in a suite at the plaza when he
owned the plaza.
But one thing we always knew about
trump,
he was a character and he lied.
Now he,
he almost lined by,
it's snowing out when it wasn't,
you know,
he'd be on my show and say highest
rating and it was all about him,
but he was a character and it was fun
and he could be very nice and generous.
Okay.
I had all those qualities,
but he was a character.
I mean,
he would call up the New York Post with
a different name and tell them stories
about Donald Trump so we can get on page
six.
That was his goal,
but precedent precedent.
Are you kidding?
Anybody,
any of us who knew him years ago?
First,
he was a moderate to central Democrat,
supported Hillary Clinton,
loved Hillary Clinton,
thought she was a great senator.
He wanted single payer health care.
He didn't care about abortion.
Come on.
Evangelicals.
I don't think Donald ever read a book,
but he's.
But he was a friendly character to be
around our wonderful guest.
A lot of fun.
Fly off the top,
but precedent precedent.
So what do you make about what happened
here?
Like I have no idea what Hillary was.
A bad candidate,
a wonderful person.
I Know Hillary very well.
Great sense of humor.
Said,
I don't know what her.
She didn't go to Wisconsin.
You get a different hillary when you
went into her interview.
Her publicly.
This is what a lot of her is that she's
very friendly and open.
The one on one.
She's good.
Yeah.
Front of an audience.
She's not.
She's not a good.
She's running for something now.
I went to a Yom Kippur service where she
was the speaker.
She was terrific.
She wasn't running for anything.
She was a senator from New York and damn
good center,
uh,
she ran a horrendous campaign and she
was not a good campaign.
I thought she won the debates,
but it almost didn't matter.
Trump became with some got elected with
that first question in the first
republican debate when he was asked
about women and did he ever call women
pigs?
And he said only Rosie O'donnell.
And he sat in the middle of all the
Republican.
Why did they see them in the middle?
It was just four on one side.
Did you really think at the end from
that moment that he thought he would
ignite something?
But I thought he was dead when he said
the thing about mccain isn't a hero.
Certainly when he got off the bus with
billy Bush,
I thought that was over.
But his base doesn't care if
evangelicals can put aside his personal
life.
He'll never lose them.
He'll never saw it.
I've never lived in weird at times.
I mean,
this is the weirdest time to every day.
Yeah.
There's a story.
Does this truly,
in all your years,
does this right now feel like a truly,
truly unique time?
Because people ask me that a of the
events.
I do,
and I think the answer is yes.
Although you always think that when
you're living it,
of course,
it's your perspective.
Do you believe that?
Somebody said one day to see what
Lincoln Center.
To hear what?
Roseville dig less night to see the
speech.
The Carter mate that he went.
Was that weird?
No,
they didn't do weird things.
They were president that I remember.
I was in the White House interviewing
George Bush and Barbara Bush said to me,
Larry suspenders and the White House,
no,
she was at the White House's place is
now.
I wonder what it's like in their
character.
The guy writes the op Ed piece in the
New York Times.
My God,
the world would book fascinating book.
We're living in those times.
What would it?
Couldn't believe it,
but I can see as you talk about it,
there's a glimmer in your eye like
there's something exciting about this.
Do you think that that's in a weird way
the the good part of this,
even if it's kind of helter skelter now.
Okay.
I'm glad I'm not on CNN.
No,
I wouldn't want to be doing panels
everyday and trump all the time.
Don't want to do that.
That's not the whole world.
Trump's not the whole world.
He thinks he's still
important.
Do you think politics actually is
because I think now there's maybe what
I'm realizing now is that this is really
about culture.
What we're fighting right now,
this,
this battle that seems to be in points
about culture.
It's about what do we really care about?
What do we like?
Not just about the INS and outs and
machinations of
too much of America is still prejudiced
against Latinos.
Blacks.
That still runs through a lot of this,
in my opinion,
people voting against their own self
interest.
Now let's face it,
with some.
Obamacare is working for a lot of
people.
Don't hear many complaints about people
who are under it and getting good
medical care.
I'm not sure that I love to do away with
it.
It was just those.
Those kinds of facts are sort of bothers
me when I see that.
Why we still have prejudice in America
and appeal to it.
I mean,
trump,
even his defendant would say he appeals
to it.
What do we need a.
We need a wall.
Do you think?
Do you think that's a play by him?
I mean,
for all the years that you knew him,
did you think he was racist or that this
is.
I never thought he was racist.
I think he was opportunities.
He was.
He took advantage of a situation,
so we used to say he wasn't smart.
He wasn't book smart.
I bet at at school he got gentlemen see
the big influences in his life or Roy
Cohn who I knew very well and his
father,
they were bad influences.
I mean,
Rog Roy Cohn was,
I liked them closing.
He was peculiar,
but he was waiting for the people that
don't know who right going is.
He was a bad guy.
He was part of the mccarthy era and
angels in America had,
he played a part in that play,
uh,
and he was affected by that.
So I never,
I never thought he was a racist,
but his narcissism was beyond belief.
I in every other sentence,
I did this,
I did that.
I'm the greatest president we've ever
had.
I think.
Just say that.
How could you say that?
So if you were sitting down with him,
I would say Donald,
why?
I spoke to them everyday during the
camp,
but not every day,
once a week during the campaign,
he knew I was voting for Hillary,
but we were friends and he would call
me.
What do you think it is?
I'm the one that is.
What do you think of that?
I got this.
What do you think?
It is something.
I'm going to do an interview with the
New York Times,
you know,
the guy,
should I do this?
And then when he was elected,
I never heard from him again.
I want to.
Do you think we can get out of this
polarization that we seem to be in?
So if we're in this unique time right
now in crazy time,
how's it going to change?
You know,
we don't have,
uh,
forcefully to.
It might be Bloomberg to lead us.
We need someone
to lead us out.
We need Gary Cooper.
Maybe George Clooney in the modern
society.
I'm not kidding.
George Clooney a bright and he is
bright.
George Clooney wouldn't be very pumping
women's vote smart as a whip.
What does that tell you though?
If we need to go to celebrities?
Do you think?
Maybe we're just in.
There it is.
That's the Internet.
That's the world we live in.
Yeah.
I like Georgia.
I'd vote for him.
Yeah.
But do you think we can get out of this,
this thing?
Well,
they say a motorcycle always comes
through everything.
George will,
who's become very anti.
Trump believes we can find a way again,
America as a way of finding a way.
I hope so.
I hope I'm around to see it.
Um,
but right now,
and you know,
one in my early,
I can name every senator 10,
10,
20 years ago,
every sound and go orrin hatch and Ted
Kennedy were great friends,
sponsored bills together.
Hatch did his eulogy that,
that wouldn't exist today.
Today.
The thing is so bad when Obama nominated
his guy for the Supreme Court and I
shouldn't forget his name
and they never brought it up.
Now of course it's a mic.
We'll get it,
we'll get it.
But not when,
when,
when we nominate people like that who
was pretty much middle of the road.
Oh,
garland.
Merrick garland.
Yeah.
If I would have Democrats now and they
take the Senate,
I would hold up any appointment until
they can have a precedent.
And a first person out of point would be
married,
called who deserved to be on that court.
Yeah.
So this is just both of them playing
politics to Dan.
We have a chance.
I,
I don't see it coming.
You know,
when Merrick Garland was nominated,
for example,
Orrin Hatch,
before he knew they would delay it,
said he's a great man.
And then it becomes party over country,
party over country.
Sad when you think it's going to change.
I think that the outrage machine that
we're running on right now,
I think it can only last for so long,
so I think it couldn't.
It'll either blow up into something much
worse and I don't even know what I mean
by that,
but I think things would actually get
much worse and some of this would
actually spill over into violence or
what my hope is,
and I think this is more a realistic
option,
is that the outrage will start running
out of steam,
like a car running out of gas and that
from that somebody,
whether maybe if you're a clooney or
whoever else,
it is just a decent human being,
a Bloomberg or something else will come
back and decency will be appreciated
because I don't think this outreach
thing can run forever.
It's too.
It's too mentally exhausting.
It's physically
was a decent man.
I've known for years with Joe Barton.
Nobody just like some wonderful father
and a third.
It's a great senator,
a great vice president.
If he were a little younger,
can you imagine he'd be,
what?
80 two or something?
Yeah,
because she can't dislike them.
You want to be vp?
No,
I couldn't take the cut in pay.
All right.
Let's,
let's finish up with some,
some big picture,
big picture stuff.
Looking back,
is there anything you would've done
differently?
We were.
When I got married
as much,
I would have gone national sooner.
I had the talent,
but I was a big fish in a smaller pond
in Miami and I liked that I'd radio
television,
cop column in the Miami Herald.
You know,
everybody knew me in Miami.
I never sent a tape to New York.
I should have.
I would have liked to gone national
sooner just just to have more success
earlier you think is to appeal to more
people.
Of course I had something.
I knew I was good.
I knew I was good at what I did and I,
I didn't really get well known,
so my fifties and I think it couldn't
happen in the thirties.
I'm not any better than I was in the
thirties.
I'm not better today than I was when I
was in my late twenties.
I was.
I was curious.
I always let my ego at the door or was
there short questions,
always got really interested in the
guests.
That never changed.
Sometimes someone will play me a tape
that they had for 30 years ago.
Still me.
I'm still.
They're still asking questions.
I think the first time I interviewed
you,
I asked you something about the ego
component relative to to interviewing
and your answer.
I loved it and I.
I've really tried to incorporate it in
what I do,
which is you said the show was called
Larry King tonight.
My ego was already stroke.
Yeah,
I'll be there tomorrow.
My model.
It's a good model of David.
Could be your model.
Could be anybody's model.
If Donald trump had this model,
we would be a better country.
This is my motto.
I never learned anything when I was
talking.
Think about it.
I never learned anything when I was
talking.
I may impart things to people.
I may have some knowledge,
but I haven't run into anything when I'm
talking.
It feels like a privilege in a way,
right?
When you have somebody great across from
you and you get this,
I'm telling you,
this hour of my life is a privilege.
Oh,
to be on the Rubin report,
to be part of what?
By the way,
census or report.
Do I get a grade?
Be graded at the.
Oh,
trust me,
the youtube,
youtube comments and shit.
I don't have the where with all.
How do you see Larry King?
That is the last thing I want to impart
on you.
All right,
final question.
Here we go.
What's it all about?
I've asked you this,
I've asked you some version of this many
times a day,
my friend.
What's it all about and what does it all
mean?
What does it mean a hundred years from
today?
Who's going to care?
John Lowenstein once hit a grand slam
home run for the Orioles to beat the
Yankees and it was crowd went crazy.
Someone said,
John,
how does it feel?
And he said,
100 million Chinese don't give a damn.
What is it all mean?
The answer is I don't know.
All right,
my friend.
Well,
despite the fact that you did not wear
suspenders today,
I did not.
I wanted to be totally casual with you.
This true.
This is what it's about.
What we just did for the last hour.
Thank you David.
Thank you.
My pleasure and thank you for the milk
check.
Alright,
you guys can check out Larry on TV and
follow him on twitter at King's.
Things.